[Music]
one of the major reasons why nothing
works in this country and all of our
institutions are collapsing is that very
few people especially those running
those institutions are capable of seeing
beyond themselves they don't care about
anything greater than themselves they
don't recognize that anything greater
than themselves can even exist they
certainly aren't focused on the larger
mission of the institution but instead
are totally enveloped
in their own egos this intense
self-focus destroys every institution
down to the smallest and most essential
one like the family
the institution can't survive if
everybody within that institution
everybody who's in charge of leading it
spends all day staring at their own
reflections
somebody needs to be focused on the
grander broader vision somebody needs to
take the long view
a view in which they are not the central
figure
but few people these days are capable of
that
there's a term that's become popular on
social media called main character
syndrome this describes people who
imagine themselves to be the protagonist
the leads
and their lives to be some sort of
cinematic feature film
in in which they are the star
you could really just use the term
narcissist here because it has basically
the same meaning except that main
character syndrome is helpful because it
captures the way that so many people
today tend to not only place themselves
at the center of the universe but also
fictionalize the universe at the same
time
they're the main characters in the story
of their lives but that story has only a
tangential relationship to the truth
i mean it's sort of based on true events
at best
we could take this main character
phenomenon and relate it back to the
collapse of our societal institutions
and there's probably no institution
that suffers more from this problem than
the education system
the problem in education today well one
of the many one of the great many
problems
is not just that so many teachers are
intensely ideological
but that they're also intensely
self-centered
which leads them to believe that it can
never be inappropriate
for them to indoctrinate their students
after all the class they're teaching is
really all about them everything's about
them they are the subject
they've been hired to teach history or
algebra or english literature or
whatever but their real job as far as
they're concerned is to shape the
students into little versions of
themselves
and all of this explains the recent
trend
of teachers coming out coming out to
their students during class
i've seen at least three videos
documenting this in just the last few
weeks we played one several days ago
where a high school teacher records
himself in class
as he called the students attention to
himself and proceeded to inform them
that he is non-binary and his preferred
pronouns are all pronouns he is all
things to all people as the apostle paul
once wrote though in a very different
context
we're not going to play that video again
but we do have two more
first here's another non-binary teacher
talking about her experiences coming out
to her students
and she's talking about them in response
to a question from another teacher who
is also non-binary and here's what she
says
you can be reasonably assured that you
are safe being out on your campus um
then do it before coming out as
non-binary um i would come out to my
students
every october on national coming out day
i would use that as an opportunity for
my students to learn how to receive
somebody coming out to them in case that
had never happened to them before and we
used it as a way to talk to each other
about empathy about connection about
trust it ended up being a wonderful
experience that i had with my students
every single year so think about what
you would have needed when you were in
high school or middle school or whatever
grade you're teaching for some students
just the knowledge that a queer adult
exists within their their world is
hugely impactful you don't really have
to do anything other than be visible for
these students to feel safer and more
accepted and more at home when they're
on campus it it does so much for
students who don't have that in other
places in their lives for that reason my
classroom is one of the gayest places
probably on the planet everything is
completely covered in rainbows i've got
flags everywhere i've got queer
literature because i want every student
that i have to know that being queer is
something that i am proud of something
that is not um a secret in my life it's
something that i care about and
something that connects me to other
people i'll end by saying that for me
being visibly queer is a non-negotiable
i introduce myself this year with my
pronouns immediately it was the one of
the first things that students learned
about me
you know somehow the most irritating
part of that was still the word
impactful
just an awful word but that's beside the
point the point is that this
pathologically self-absorbed narcissist
enjoys the attention and
self-congratulation of coming out so
much that she does it every year
she has by her own admission turned her
entire classroom into a temple to
herself
the only thing that's missing is like
the uh incense and the the hooded monks
chanting in an ancient language
as is this religious temple of
self-worship every day in her classroom
it is a chance for all of her students
to join her in worshiping herself it is
a celebration of her own sexual
proclivities and she doesn't feel weird
about inviting kids to take part in that
celebration or forcing them to in fact
because this is her we're talking about
and what could be more important what
subject could be more pressing
than the subject of herself that was
also the approach of the teacher in the
next clip who recorded a video
sharing her thoughts after having just
come out to her sixth grade students
it was important that the sixth graders
be told you know who she likes to sleep
with
they really needed to know that
information about their teacher's sexual
behavior so she was sure to inform them
so i just
came out to my students
[Music]
i've been wanting to do this for the
past two years
sorry i'm like so emotional
um and i just haven't had the courage to
do it
out of fear of just judgment mostly from
their parents
but
i had these kids in fourth grade and
now i have them in six and i'm sending
them to middle school and i love these
kids so much and i trust them and they
make me feel safe and
i know they love me and
just felt right and i i did it and
it was so beautiful
[Music]
they had so many questions which i loved
they wanted to learn and they wanted to
learn about me and
they were so eager and
a few of them clapped which was
so precious
so you notice how this was a spontaneous
and emotional video revealing her true
feelings and yet she took the time to
edit
and add the inspirational soundtrack in
the background
i mean it's hard to think of a better
example of main character syndrome than
that notice also how she says that um
they make me feel safe
that's an adult woman a teacher
referring to the 11 year olds in her
classroom
and she says that um
they wanted to learn about me
and maybe they did
or maybe they felt forced to pretend
that they did but whatever the case do
we send kids to school so so that they
can learn about their teachers
as far as these teachers are concerned
the answer is yes what subject could be
more important than the subject of
themselves and on the subject of
themselves
what could be a more important detail
than their sex lives
see they see themselves as defined by
their sex lives and they see the world
as revolving around themselves which
means that the world revolves around
their sex lives
this mentality
makes for dysfunctional people
and with enough of these people in the
education system whatever their sexual
orientation it makes for a dysfunctional
education system
and that is why teachers who come out to
their students
are today certainly
and finally
cancelled
hey listen
hit the subscribe button do it right now
i demand it and i thank you for your
compliance it is somewhat appreciated